[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
word of
encourag good afternoon everyone how are
you y it's so nice to see everybody's
happy
faces um a few announcements before we
get going today uh Five Loaves service
day we'll be serving at Five Loaves uh
which is the local food food bank um as
a table community on Saturday March 15th
from 8:30 to 12:30 um amm to P p.m. uh
this is a familyfriendly opportunity and
we will be passing out food and helping
at the warehouse uh you can RSVP by
scanning the QR code
um Ash Wednesday um lint happens this
week as we go into that season um so Ash
Wednesday Ser service will be on
Wednesday uh we do not have a service
but we encourage you to attend saxi
first Ash Wednesday service that begins
right here 700 p.m. on Wednesday
night um
accessibility if you are anxious about
being in a church setting part of a
disability Community or just feeling
fidgety uh we have an accessibility
bucket available for you over the table
to my
left um there are noise cancelling
headphones fidgets coloring sheets uh we
just ask that you return them to the
bucket at the end of
service um we've lift the candles to my
left and right these candles are a sign
of the presence of Christ Among Us the
fully Divine and fully
human um so as we take a few moments and
enter into a space of worship we exit
the Kingdom of noise hurry and
productivity we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred Space a place for
prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ the
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart and
that we may all come
home thank you Jared would you guys
stand with us as we enter into worship
tonight and as always um whatever you
carry into this space is welcome here
whatever emotions struggles feelings um
whatever highs or lows we want to bring
those together as a community and lift
those up before God believing that he
hears us and he is with us so let's just
keep that in mind as we sing these songs
together
[Music]
and Tear Down the Walls of f every wall
built up every wall buil up cuz you
deserve every piece in my heart every
piece in my heart every piece in my
heart come Tear Down the Walls of fil
every wall of fil every wall I buil up
cuz you deserve every pce of my heart
every in my heart every pce of My
Heart
Lord I am trusting that you are a
faithful father all that you have it is
good you're a gener
scar like no other won't you come and
break do to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open
hands closer and closer it dra me in as
the deps of my heart lay before you
again over and over and over again I am
bring in my heart to you with open
hands closer and closer you draw in me
in as the deps of my heart lay before
you
again
Lord I am trusting that you are a
faithful father and all that you have it
is your
generous G your love's like no other
won't you come and break through to the
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands closer and closer you're draw me
as the deps of my heart lay before you
again
and Tear Down the Walls I buil every
wall I built up every wall that build up
cuz you deserve every piece my heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
my
heart come Tear Down the Walls I buil up
every wall
bu every wall
build cuz you deserve every peace in my
heart every pece in my heart every pece
of my
heart all right our kids are dismissed
to go to their classrooms for just a
little bit and we're going to transition
into our child dedication
um oh actually we wanted the kids to
stay in here for the kids dedication so
sorry about that our kids are going to
stay with us for just a brief moment
while we do child
dedications all right so you all
everyone can go ahead and take a
seat and
uh my name is Brett Brett Tilford I'm
the pastor here and uh yeah it's a a joy
to welcome you into this space so uh
tonight we have something just a really
really special um ceremony and uh the
purpose of this is really twofold um
it's of this child dedication ceremony
it's a it's for the parents of these
kiddos to be able to um just communicate
and commit um their own heart to raise
their child or their children in the way
of Jesus Christ uh in the way of great
love and um so it's kind of part of it
and the other part of it is uh it's a
chance for us as a church Community not
only to witness that but also um to
support them in that process and to say
hey um we're committing to you as well
we're we're committing uh we know how
incredibly difficult raising children
can be it is not for the faint of Art
and no one needs to do that alone right
and and so we as a church Community
we're gathering around these folks and
uh supporting and loving them in this um
Journey so um with that in mind what I'm
going to do is invite all of you to go
ahead and um kind of join in with this
liturgy so large parts of it I'll be
reading but then there's always a
response um and in fact you know what
let's go ahead and have the the parents
and the kids uh who are dedicating their
children go ahead and come forward um at
this
time hey
Hannah Joe's ready if y'all want to come
here and then y'all want to stand right
here that's
perfect um so this is the Steals and the
Grays and oh we could not be more
excited just to yeah to have this moment
with y'all and just to be able to
support you in this uh in this journey
so um I'm going to go ahead and uh for
this reading there'll be a a short
response for you parents as we kind of
go through um and then at the very end
the church there's one point where it'll
say you know all church and that's your
moment and you can go ahead and commit
how um we will commit to do this you
know to for them so um let's go ahead
and read
this I believe this child is a gift from
God and I Endeavor to express this truth
in my actions and my words
words
believe I commit to surround this child
with an atmosphere of unconditional love
and to guide them toward the way of
Jesus and the fruit of the Holy
Spirit I will be present and engaged
even when the journey is rough I will
pray for and with my child when we are
struggling or when we are celebrating I
commit to listen when I would rather
yell to speak the truth when it is
uncomfortable and to be patient when I
am tired I will look for the good work
God is doing in my child and call it
forward you can go ahead and respond
with this I will there you
go I will do my best to be a living
example of Christ transforming love and
parent from the values I see lived out
in the
gospel I
will I realize parenting can be
challenging and I acknowledge my need
for support and encouragement from my
church
Community I acknowled I think that's
what yeah I acknowledge my
need and church do you commit to love
and care for this child will you listen
to them encourage them and patiently
bear with them as they discover who they
are in Christ and you can respond we
will
will in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit so we're now going
to take a few minutes to uh pray over
these children and their uh families so
if you are someone that the parent have
um asked to be up here during this time
of prayer whether you're like a family
member who's here today or maybe a
friend of the family who's you they ask
you to pray over them you can go ahead
and make your way forward now and
uh during this time I encourage all of
you to uh say just your own quiet
prayers for each of these families the
graves the Steals and just lift them up
in your own uh heart and mind as we take
a few minutes to do this and then I'll
close us in prayer in uh in just a bit
I can't see you
[Music]
ahead and pray with me gracious God
Giver of all life we pray for these
parents and Guardians give them wisdom
and patience let your peace and joy
dwell in their
homes instruct them in your truth
strengthen them in faith sustain them
through prayer order their lives by love
we pray for these children be gracious
to them draw them to yourself help them
to love and Trust Christ
we pray that you will grow them in the
faith that they might mature and
represent you well to the world I pray
over this community may we be strong and
a stable context of love and belonging
for each of these children in the loving
and Powerful name of Jesus I pray
amen amen
amen oh beautiful thanks thanks so much
for participating in that time with us
um so next I want to invite up Maggie
and the kids team uh cuz we have we got
all the cool things this morning or
tonight um oh did we change
it oh okay we're we're changing it and
you all do your thing never mind uh kids
are dism is that what I'm saying
cool over at the
[Music]
doors we will see you guys later you'll
have so much fun
[Music]
and as we transition I just wanted to
read this passage out of Psalm
46 um we've had a lot go u a lot happen
in our community over these last few
weeks and uh especially this week this
passage has stood out to
me God is our refuge and our strength
and ever presentent help in
trouble therefore we will not fear
though the Earth gives way and the
mountains fall into the heart of the sea
though its Waters Roar and foam and the
mountains Quake with their
surging there is a river whose streams
make glad the city of God the holy place
where the most high
dwells God is within her she will not
fall the Lord Almighty is with us
the god of Jacob is our
[Music]
Fortress would you guys stand with us
again as we sing
[Music]
and how can I
respond to the love you have lavished
on
me how can I
[Music]
respond to the love you have lavished
on
we I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that you I have a heart thats for
[Music]
you and every part of
me wants to Love You Like You Love
Me Lord
[Music]
every part of
me wants to love you like you love
me my
Lord I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart thats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I have a heart that beats
for you I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart thats for you I have
a life I'll give to
I have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a I'll give to you I
have a heart thats for you I have a
heart thats for you I have a heart that
peace for you I have a life I'll give to
you I have
life give to you I have a give to you I
have a life of give to
[Music]
you I don't
have I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
I don't
have I have a heart that beats for I
have a heart that beats for
you and I will build my
life upon your love it is a firm
[Music]
and I will put my
trust you
alone and I will not be
sh I will not be Shen
[Music]
sing
worthy worthy
of we could
sing worthy of all the praise we could
ever
[Music]
worthy of every bre we could ever Brea
we live for
[Music]
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could ever
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
Brea we live for
you we live for
you and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes
wonder and show me who you are and F me
with your heart and Lead me and you love
to
those around
[Music]
and I will build my life
upon your love it is
a ground
I will put my trust in
you and I will not be
sh and I will build the
light upon your love it is a
found and I will put my trust in you
are I will not be
[Music]
shly you there is none beside you open
up my eyes
in Wonder and show me who you are and
fill me with your heart andad me in your
love to
those
[Music]
me God would you continue to lead us in
love
would you move us forward by your spirit
towards the nature and the character of
Jesus someone who laid his life
down someone who gave of
himself humble in
spirit
just and true
[Music]
God would you continue to lead us
forward in your
ways shape our hearts after your hearts
God would you light our
path would you be a lamp unto our
feet we look to you
God be our everpresent help in time of
trouble
be the lifter of our
head we ask these things in jesus'
name
amen all right you guys can be seated
and as you do will you welcome the
people around you and say hello and then
Maggie will transition us into our next
portion all right
well thank you guys for being with us
and as Brett started to mention earlier
we do have a little special thing
tonight that we want to share with you
so if our big kids class are youall
ready back there y'all want to come on
out we've been working guys we've been
working hard and um since
August um our big kids class which is
first graders all the way through sixth
graders have been memorizing the books
of the Old Testament together so y'all
come up here and um we have I'll just
acknowledge a few of our teachers in the
room um Casey and JY are the two
teachers that are leading them in here
tonight um also I saw Lily sitting Lily
is in the back she teaches them um in
our big kids class Charles Kaiser I
don't think is here tonight but he's one
of our big kids teacher um myself and
Katie and Abby salsman are also in our
big kids class and um up until this
point Brock has been also teaching these
kids with us every week and um so this
is like something that we've been
working on and tonight what are you guys
about to get to do in just a minute
books the Bible well okay but then what
happens after that we get to play a game
we get party we're partying tonight we
have of all the things they chose
roses
roses they could have had ice cream they
could have done a popcorn party they
could have done pizza and they chose
roses so we're partying with roses but
for this moment can y'all start giving
us the we will we will rock you beat are
y'all ready so let's do
it y'all can help us give us a
little okay are youall
ready here we go Genesis EX this
Leviticus
numers
Judes and
Samuel King
[Music]
and Danel
[Applause]
[Music]
Malachi so I don't know how many of you
could say all the books of the Old
Testament but they could take you to
school on this one so we just wanted to
let you guys see a little peek into what
they've been working on you guys did
good can you'all give them one more
round of
applause you can go eat Rosas go do your
thing thank you
so good have to follow that they uh I
liked how they're like all so strong in
the beginning and they're like starting
to get into those minor profits and it's
like oh gosh
[Music]
oh well um welcome like I mentioned
earlier my name is Brett and uh yeah
it's good to good to be with you to
welcome you into this space as always
that includes those joining us online
y'all are not forgotten don't get forget
your uh communion stuff for later in the
service and um anyone here tonight who
is new thank you for um being being here
so um you know one of the very unique
things about being part of a just a
small Church community is that we very
much uh go through things together and
um
you know many of us tonight are um
grieving the loss of a dear friend at
the table named Brock Ellison um who
some of you many of you have heard um
but he passed away late Tuesday night um
from what's believed to be a heart
attack and um it's just it's just a
tremendous loss um for us as a community
um not only because of all the various
hats brought wore and he wore many man
he was you heard him already mention
about kids ministry uh he did a lot of
the prep and Leadership for communion
and um helped me with like website and
SEO kind of stuff you know so there's
lots of roles and hats and and things
like that um but honestly beyond all of
that it was just who he was for those of
you who knew him like just a kind man
just good just good-hearted and I I I I
take that to to be one of the highest
peaks of the Christian Life um very
underrated in this world just just a a
good-heartedness in fact he was so good
I remember when I was first interacting
with him I was almost a little
suspicious CU I was like are you like is
there some angle here or like are you
buttering me up for I don't know like
what's going on and no it just turned
out that's just who he was just very
loving just completely uh
guess you know just um fully
himself and uh it was so good to to see
um just the path like where he was at
the end of his life with Christ it was
just a beautiful thing to behold like he
um some of you don't know but for years
back at Pleasant Valley I shouldn't say
for years but when we were back at
Pleasant Valley United Methodist Church
across town um he was contemplating
attending the table but he but he had a
lot of um Church trauma honestly
spiritual trauma and things embodied and
he was it was very um as a gay man it
was just it was a lot for him to come
into a church space again after his
experiences in the past so for he said
literally weeks he pulled into the
parking lot and then pulled out and he
pulled into the parking lot the next
Sunday and then pulled out and he pulled
in and then pulled out and then pulled
in and then pulled out like just over
and and I'm so glad that one day he had
the courage and he walked through those
doors and he completely changed all of
our lives like we're never we'll never
be the same because of that you know
like that
relationship uh just incredible so
um
yeah so we don't know details yet of
when his service will be um uh but
certainly we I'll keep you on the loop
if you're uh a part of like get my texts
weekly texts and things you know I'm
happy to um communicate things via that
and uh and of course word will spread um
so I you know I as I was thinking just
for this Sunday and such
um kind of what to say I U I think it
was it's fitting um I had written this
message before uh hearing about Brock
but um It's the final Sunday in the
season of epiphany it's also known as
Transfiguration Sunday and uh It just
strikes me as a very
appropriate uh text for um kind of this
this moment so the title of my message
tonight is waking
up waking up our scripture is Luke
chapter 9: 28 through
36 about eight days after Jesus said
this he took Peter John and James with
him and went up onto a mountain to pray
as he was praying the appearance of his
face changed and his clothes became as
bright as a flash of lightning two men
Moses and Elijah appeared in glorious
Splendor talking with
Jesus they spoke about his departure
which he was about to bring to
fulfillment at
Jerusalem Peter and his companions were
very sleepy but when they became fully
awake they saw his
glory and the two men standing with him
as the men were leaving Peter uh as as
men were leaving Jesus Peter said to him
Master it's good for us to be here let
us put up three shelters one for you one
for Moses and one for Elijah he did not
know what he was
saying while he was speaking a cloud
appeared and covered them and they were
afraid as they entered the cloud a voice
came from the clouds saying this is my
son whom I've chosen listen to him when
the voice had spoken they found that
Jesus was
alone the disciples kept this to
themselves and did not tell anyone at
that time what they had
seen it's a A fitting passage and I
think you can um see kind of what I have
in mind what I'm saying it feels
appropriate um for today because it's
very much a passage that's walking that
line between heaven and
earth right the the glory of God kind of
breaking
through and how that glory is is
actually within and as I'll go later in
the message um it's not only within
Jesus but it's actually within each and
every one of
us so here's my uh kind of my big idea
for today and uh I should mention I'm
drawing for this language of like
growing up and waking up and some of
those terms I'm I'm drawn on the uh the
philosopher Ken Wilbur integral
philosopher kin Wilbur for some of that
language um but this quote isn't his
this is this is me kind of drawing from
his word so the deepest goal of
Christian spiritual practice sacraments
and scripture
study it isn't growing up it isn't
cleaning up or showing
up the deepest goal is waking
up realizing our shared nature with God
in
Christ in other words being
transfigured that's the work that's the
thing so let's kind of unpack this step
by step what do I mean you know growing
up cleaning up showing up and then we'll
get to waking up um
growing up you know growing up it's kind
of what it sounds like uh it's maturing
you know maturing growing up all of us
uh we got to grow up some and um you
know different theologians and
psychologists and people have mapped
this in like different ways the various
ways that we all grow up um and I think
of like even in the Bible something like
the Book of Proverbs would be very much
like a growing up kind of book you know
it's it's like do this stop being dumb
stop being an idiot you know it's like
grow up you got to leave those ways
behind and like come on get on the right
track here adult you know and that's uh
that's that's kind of what growing UPS
uh all about you know we got to mature
we got to learn to put off present
pleasure for later gain that's like a
big part of growing up isn't it like the
the childish mind is just like I just
want it now you know I just want candy
now cuz it tastes good you know and and
I've heard someone say that uh uh
parenting is basically being someone
else's prefrontal cortex uh cortex and
that's you know it's that that rational
long-term planning you know that's what
you do on behalf of someone and this is
what growing up is about you know it's
like hey come on bring this online think
this through you know uh and it's
important you know and for we grow up of
course in various ways um we can have
mentors and of course our parents can
play a role and huge role um there's I
was even thinking of like uh the role of
like sports Youth Sports and things
plays a huge part of people's growing up
kind of process I I don't know um how
that played out for you but for me I was
on Club swimming uh growing up and uh I
still look back like that was still like
the some of the hardest things I've ever
done is those darn swim practices just
exhausting every year we had this thing
called uh Christmas
training which it was not in the
Christmas spirit it had nothing to do
with it was basically like our swim
coach is like oh good you know I have to
go to school you can swim more you know
and so we had at least two sometimes
three uh 2hour practices a day and it
was just oh it was brutal I remember I
was so exhausted I went to a uh youth
group Christmas party one night you know
because of course right in that time
frame and uh I just went behind the
couch everyone's like yeah they're doing
their thing playing games I went behind
the couch I just went to sleep just fell
so just like I'm exhausted you know
Christmas training but it did was
formative you know like I kind of
learned like well I don't feel like it
and it's like sorry you committed you're
you know do you have a goal do you have
a thing you're working for okay well
that's so that's growing up and it's
interesting for each of these growing up
cleaning up showing up you can kind of
um think of how different churches latch
on and emphasize certain things you know
so I've Loved this framework to kind of
think of even sermons can be like is
this a growing up sermon is this like a
cleaning up is this a showing up is this
you know like what's the uh and I think
many churches um
kind of tend towards the growing up you
know kind of like a lot of Life advice
on like come on get your finances in
order and do the thing and you know I me
um you'll notice I'm not much of a
growing up kind of preacher for those
who've been here a while and I kind of
hope and assume you've had some growing
up you know and then we're kind of going
on from there um so okay so that's
growing up and that matters that's
important
um and then we have cleaning up clean up
this is uh a bit different this is I
would call this kind of like it's the
emotional healing side of life it's it's
healing integrating those aspects of
ourselves that we might be really
tempted to run from uh past traumas past
wounds um kind of psychological shadows
and patterns of addiction and avoidance
and you know all the ways we like fight
flight freeze you know and and moments
and kind of dysfunction and uh
yeah this is where things like you know
therapy spiritual Direction um inogram
kind of stuff can be all very very um
helpful right because it's unearthing
those kind of unconscious motivations
and
fears um all the ways we're kind of
still protecting five-year-old us you
know and uh but and those things that
have been driving us our whole life only
we didn't realize it by the way our Pro
our ability and kind of how we responded
to Brock's
passing uh might have been revealed
there in a way right in essence to do um
like it it kind of tells us the degree
to which we've done some kind of
cleaning up emotional work where we can
handle some big feelings and some big
grief and some big loss or not so much
and we go off to the bar and get
hammered or you know whatever like we
kind of COPE in unhealthy ways um so it
is it's it's revealing so so you got
growing up um you got cleaning up and uh
and then we've got showing up this would
be social contribution right uh how do
you show up in the world it could be
through through your work or
volunteering or leading a Meetup or
doing community activist kind of work or
getting involved in politics or starting
or supporting a nonprofit or just flat
out living your life in public you know
like if you're not a hermit well then
you're you're there engaged in the world
and uh kind of showing up and I mean you
see this in the Life of Christ in his
public ministry right where he's out
there he's healing he's teaching he's
preaching he's um having meals with
people uh Charelle Russell spoke to this
really beautifully last week the ways
that Jesus went around just doing good
doing good I think again of Brock who
showed up and oh showed up partly
because he' done some of that growing up
cleaning up you know him to get out of
that car and actually come inside you um
so it's it's incredible right so ideally
of course we would be growing up
cleaning up you know showing up uh
throughout our life and uh again
thinking of churches and things you can
think of um churches who really
emphasize the showing up kind of aspects
right the social justice Ministries and
the the Heart of Jesus in that that way
um and it can be incredibly powerful so
growing up cleaning up showing up all
needed um my point in this message is
not to say oh that one's not needed or
no no no all needed all necessary all
essential
however they are not an end in and of
themselves they are in support of
something else that something else is
waking up but what is waking up it's
really trying to give some language to
all those mysterious scriptures you know
uh oh I I live but not I Christ lives
within me um it's all the language in
the Christian Mystics of Oneness and
Union and um Transfiguration to come
back to our Luke 9 passage and it's
called by many names throughout
scripture I mean Jesus called it the
kingdom of God the Kingdom of Heaven
which is within I think also of uh uh
Gospel of John about abide in me as I
abide in you just as br cannot bear
fruit by itself unless it abides in the
vine neither can you unless you abide in
me right and it's like what is that
getting what's that getting at waking up
waking up waking up it's what Paul
called having the mind of Christ what
the desert fathers and mothers called
hesia uh inner Stillness or silence
Meister echart the great German
Theologian called it the birth of God in
the soul St Teresa of avalu described it
as a spiritual awakening leading to
Divine Union similarly St John the cross
talked about the dark KN of the soul
that leads to a sense of Union with god
brother Lawrence called it the practice
of the presence of God Thomas Merton
called it the falling away of the false
self and the revelation of our true self
or is in our passage today you could
simply think of it as
Transfiguration of course in the end uh
these are all just words words words
words words words we we spoke about this
a few weeks back it's a little bit like
the difference between
a going to a restaurant and reading the
menu versus
eating and uh ultimately people can get
really hung up on these words you know
what's your preferred word or or what
that word doesn't sound right to me
Oneness or that's weird or you know uh I
don't know it's like but but again we
get lost in arguing about the words when
the point of course is always the meal
the eating it' be so dumb to go to a
restaurant argue about the menu like
what's your favorite thing well I
disagree that's the dumbest thing you
know it's like what the point is eating
right in the same way um we too are
invited into something very very real to
put it kind of succinctly the
Transfiguration of
Awakening occurs in me as the clouds of
ego the egoic Mind depart revealing the
Luminous sky ey of God's glory God's
Beauty God's presence within each and
every one of
you and church this is what we need we
need to wake up we need to wake up but
we need to not just be scriptures and
words and ideas that we haggle about we
we need it to be the the lived
reality in the soul
not just imitating Christ
externally but uh through the spirit
becoming right oneing as Julian of
norwitch put it oneing ourselves with
God in
Christ as we talked about last year on
this exact Sunday Transfiguration it's
not about becoming something I am not in
the same way um that the Transfiguration
described here in the Gospel of Luke
you'll notice this is not Jesus becoming
something he was not like whoa I thought
he was just a human being you know and
then all of a sudden he's shining like
the sun and you know uh no no no it's
it's it's a
revelation externally of who he always
is and has been and will be
internally right and now the hard thing
for us to kind of wrap our minds around
but it's the truth of the Gospel uh is
that through Christ we to are invited
into the transfiguring
process right that's like that's the
step that we too are initiated into the
process of
Awakening now you say okay sounds very
interesting but H H how like how do I
start to wake up a little more clear on
like growing up cleaning up showing up I
feel like I could you know go to therapy
or do some take some steps there of like
this waking up thing you know H how do
how do I do it um that's a big question
to be clear Way Beyond the scope of like
oh I'll just explain it all right now
you know um but we can at least start to
get at some of what it it looks like um
so the waking up process I'll say this
think of it like this it's not so much
about doing things or adding things
again because it's not I need to become
someone who I'm
not uh think of it more like um I I I
wake up by learning to Cease the mental
emotional processes that contribute to
my Slumber in other words it's a it's
much more about a
stopping a Letting Go which is why then
what is within the the Holy Spirit who
is within can then
shine out of
you right so it's a it's a it's a kind
of SE ceasing in other words by stopping
turning back repenting it's an
unlearning it's a
surrendering um one metaphor people are
fond of in this regard is uh you may
have heard it is the to describe the
egoic mind as the monkey mind it's that
crazy monkey in our heads jumping here
now there now there now there chattering
away all day every day keeping us
perpetually distracted stressed angry
and lost in
thought so that monkey in essence has to
go you got to stop feeding the monkey
mind monkey
food so here's uh some examples of
monkey food
arguing anyone love
arguing I love arguing you know it's
something that feels so good you know
what I mean like I want to win you know
what I mean like I want to win and that
and it's and it's something jumping out
of me and I and I
and this is and this is why I love the
metaphor of awake asleep because it's
like we get taken over if you had this
experience it's like one minute you're
there you're present the the appropriate
Christ centered response can come forth
and then all of the sudden you get
hijacked you're just reaction you're
just and it just takes over and you're
arguing and before you know it you're
saying things you would like never you
would never want to say if you were in
your right mind that's the whole thing
you're
asleep in the metaphor you get it you
know what I mean you're asleep you're
not you're not there you're gone just
arguing just another one blaming kind of
that similar it's not it's not my fault
it's your fault your fault it's you it's
this it's that it's them it's and that
again that we get in that mode we just
we we don't even know what's come over
us we we are unaware PR we we are asleep
demanding making demands on the world oh
that feels nice you know it should be
like this it should be like that they
should be like this and not like that
and you know demanding sort of a verbal
form of
controlling uh which this controlling
can be more subtle just all the ways
we're just kind of trying to control the
world all the people around us I think
this is something um if you think of
like just quickly reflect on the Life of
Christ if you've read the gospels and
you're familiar with the life of Jesus
how often did you see him arguing
blaming demanding
controlling you know why not very often
because he was
awake not
hijacked not running around like a
chicken with his head cut off not
knowing what he's saying or doing like
no no no he's there present allow the
spirit of God remember he what he said I
don't say anything except what I hear
the father saying I don't do anything
except what I hear the father doing
awake
awake in fact just go one day and just
notice tune in every time you're doing
one of these things it's
humbling it's humbling but what happens
as I step back from these processes
slowly but surely we learn to catch
ourselves and then we can surrender it
experience the person the situation we
can surrender it to God and begin to
relax and slowly but surely that monkey
mind quiets down a life of prayer and CH
Christ's presence overtakes us you know
I was thinking this week um when I got
the news about Brock I I was very
tempted to go into this Slumber mode
like it hit me I couldn't I just could I
could not believe it I know it's cliche
to say but I just couldn't I still
honestly just a part of me I'm like no
it's a joke like he I just expect him to
come walking through any minute you know
what I mean like gotcha you know
something like it's tost a joke um and I
I just can't believe it and I found
um my mind going off in all sorts of
directions like from the kind of
practical side I started to think about
I kind of had a fear of like oh he was
carrying so much with our website and
helping me so much and like Google ads a
very things and I'm just like oh my gosh
and my mind like starts churning you
know and then I start going down the
path of regret I'm like all the things
like I didn't say to him I didn't get to
say I didn't I really thought for sure I
was going to see him this Sunday you
know and and kind of going down these
roads and I realized like oh it's just
my mind's way of putting me to sleep
again it's like the pain I just want to
go to sleep instead
of taking a deep
breath and just being
present and being grateful for who he
was in the life he
lived and allowing myself to feel I sat
out on my uh front porch after I heard
initially within the first hour I just
had almost no emotional reaction um and
then as I sat down
in aoud just some space you know I
um I just had a good cry you know I
think it was his hugs I was really
looking forward to at least one more
Brock hug you know one
more
and all of a sudden I found myself open
again gentle more gentle more
tenderhearted you know and I think the
trick is this is how Christ invites us
to go through our Liv life just
here
awake awake not lost in the monkey mind
running around going crazy no no no no
when you catch yourself doing that just
come back just come back that's all
Christ asks of us and as we do that oh
we find the spirit of God welling up
within us so in closing what I want you
to do I just want you to realize this
week There's nothing in your life more
important than you're waking up growing
up cleaning up so that you can show up
Journey nothing more important than
that and I would add that of all of
those I think waking up is the first and
most important I really believe as a
church we're in a strong season of less
intellectualization more contemplation
less just reading scripture more praying
scripture less attending Sunday service
or meetups a much more mindful prayerful
bodyful awake engagement of Sunday
service and meetups less busying
ourselves with frenetic activity more
Spirit inspired showing
up so I'll leave it to you to discern
exactly how that needs to look in your
own life but I encourage you to really
give yourself to it listen to the Holy
Spirit do which he's inviting you to do
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night that Jesus was betrayed
he had won final meal with his disciples
at that meal held up a loaf of bread and
he broke it he said this is my body
that's broken for you take it and eat
then he held up a cup of wine said this
is my blood it's shed for you whenever
you eat this bread whenever you drink
this cup remember me remember
me so tonight as uh we come forward I
just encourage you to uh do it in that
awake mentality not not too worried
about past and future and what could
have been and this and that and just but
just present just here allow Christ to
meet you um in the bread and in the
wine so um the way we go about this
tonight we'll just go row by row um
forming one line right here in the
middle so when the FR row is done and
the second row can come up and and so on
and so forth we practice what's called
an Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate
then you are you're free to do that
regardless of your exact like you know
Christian affiliation or denominational
background or something that effect um
you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like some folks like to
take right away others like to come and
need kneel here at the front some like
to return to their seats and partake
there but no one will lead you through
the exact moment of your um taking of
the elements so this is the table not of
the church but of the
Lord It's Made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who failed come come because it's
the Lord Jesus himself who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet them here come to
the table
[Music]
all
for
[Music]
we're going to close with the the hymn
called um take my life and you guys are
welcome to stand with us and sing along
if you would like
um but this as I I found out the news
about Brock
and the words of the song Just
Echo his life and the way that he
interacted with us as a community the
way he loved so
well it was rare to find
someone in this church Circle who who
wasn't annoyed by all the boy energy
that we had going on
here Brock was so special and he was
like on their team like he was rooting
for them you
know and I'll never forget that how he
loved even when it was difficult even
when it was
inconvenient
stressful so anyway I just pray that our
lives will be marked by that same kind
of love that goodness that kindness that
BR was talking about and that we would
lay our lives down as an offering to be
used by
Jesus because that's how he lived and
I'll never forget that about him
[Music]
Let It
Be
[Music]
consecrated Lord to
the take
my and my days
let them flow in
ceaseless
praise let them flow in
ceaseless pra
[Music]
take my
hands and
let at the
impulse of thy
love take my feet and let them
be Swift and beautiful
for
thee Swift and
[Music]
beautiful for
the so take my voice and let me
[Music]
sing
only for my
he take my lips and let them
be filled with
MES
fory filled with
MES for
[Music]
love my Lord I
pour at thy feet
it take myself
and I will
be
ever for
the
only all for
thee
only all for the
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new
here we would love for you to fill out a
card at the table on your way out to my
left or scan the QR code on the screen
and fill out the online visitor card as
a reminder uh meetups are happening we
can all use more relational support and
spiritual connection the way we do that
at the table is through our meetups if
you are not part of a Meetup scan the QR
code to find one that works for
you generosity is a key aspect of
life and adoration and worship if the
table is your church home then we invite
you to scan the QR code and give
financially or visit theable tx.org
as we finish tonight let me send you in
this week with a
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and it
is true on your worst
day so as you go into this week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the
assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed and
we'll see you next Sunday
[Music]
and let it
be
[Music]
cons Lord to
the take my moment
my
days let them
flow
ceas
praise let them
[Music]
flow
ceaseless prise